in the lobby a financial piece Plaza
she's here she's kind of bashful Justine
is whether say Justine how are you I'm
so excited to be here it's so surreal we
are so glad you're here where do you
live I live in Manhattan Kansas
absolutely it's a bit of a haul to
Nashville it is about 10 hour drive yeah
pretty serious but here to do a
debt-free scream that's correct
all right and how much have you paid off
I've paid off $35,000 phenomenal how
long did that take you two years and
five months good for you making what
kind of money
I started off making thirty three
thousand dollars up to forty-one
thousand dollars good for you what do
you do for a living I work for a big
university in Manhattan Kansas maybe
people know it and there are marketing
and communications division oh you do
very cool very cool so that would be the
Jayhawks oh no that's that's the school
down the river
I couldn't resist all again we bleed
purple I hear you well we're glad you're
here thanks for doing this now how much
what was the debt what kind of debt it
was all student loans hmm so what
happened two and a half years ago to
justine that you said we got to change
this well it actually started in 2008 um
I was in college at the time living in
my sorority house and my mom got laid
off from a big telecommunications
corporation a few days later my Nana
passed away and my dad was working
overtime and I remember getting that
phone call from my mom I was in my
sorority house and she said Justine we
we can't help you anymore financially
you are on your own
I remember just sobbing in the corner of
my sorority house amongst all these
other girls who were given that support
from their parents on a silver spoon and
here I was not knowing how to make ends
meet so I got a job working as a
waitress at a restaurant and paid as
much as I could with the cash that I was
making and then when I got out of school
three years ago I went back in read your
book financial piece revisited and
thought I can do this and I can make
this possible within five years
that was my goal and then I made it in
two years five months I love it
congratulations you so what was the
hardest thing you did while you were
getting out of that um the hardest part
was paying more than the minimum payment
so I viewed that extra cash as a
security blanket and I would sit on my
little molehill of cash and slowly give
the lender their money and then the
thing that changed was I stopped viewing
it as my money and I started viewing it
as God's money and I said God tell me
what to do with this and he said just
give it do it you can do it you're going
to get it back anyways so that really
was a hinge point for me and then I was
debt free and I made that last payment
and I saw the loan account go down to
zero balance and I thought okay that's
it what's next and it wasn't until the
next month when I had my paycheck and I
wasn't putting $1,000 $2,000 towards the
loan I got to keep that money hmm
and then that's really what made me feel
good yeah well the having the the scar
of kind of getting dropped on your head
in the sorority house phone call and
that insecurity after that it's natural
to say hey I need a little pile of money
to lean on mm-hmm
and instead of paying it down on the
debt it sound like it was a spiritual
experience where you just had lean on
God instead oh yeah it definitely was
and uh in the middle of that I dubbed my
fortunate accident
I Drive a 2002 Ford zx2 and we had our
first ice storm in Kansas City I was
living in Kansas City at the time and I
got rear-ended so hard that insurance
deemed my car totaled they bent the
frame and I looked my bumper wasn't
shreds hmm and so I had to make a
decision do I take out a loan and get a
new car or do I keep driving and make
this happen and insurance gave me money
and a salvage title and they said you
can have this and I said okay I'm going
to do this so my dad and I went to you
pullet junkyard and found the exact same
bumper same color model for 25 bucks
I was still driving it
today I love it bent frame and all they
frame it all and my fiancee god bless
and put it on there with bolts and
everything so it looks great there we go
ready to go I love it well when you
survive this at no older than you are
you can do anything there's nothing that
can stop you now
I mean you set a goal you went and got
it there's just a sense of dignity a
sense of completion isn't there I feel
very lucky very blessed and I really owe
it a lot to my support group you know my
fiancee we just got engaged
a month ago and he said as a joke I'm
not going to marry you if you're in debt
let's get this thing wrapped up just so
we can get married so he's here with me
today and I love him so much
and you know my support group with my
family my parents my sisters and really
the FPU class that we went to together
in Manhattan has been such a blessing
and I encourage anybody who is listening
today that if they're going through this
get your support group and if that's not
your parents or your family they don't
understand then really you can find that
support group in your FPU class too
absolutely all right well put him on the
headsets with him get him on there come
on down come on down what's his name
again
it's Kyle all right I met Kyle a minute
ago at the break but I didn't know what
he I didn't know what the relationship
was I wanted us just but if you're a
fiancee you're qualified to yell yes and
you can you can join in the conversation
we've been dating three years now and so
he's watched me go through this entire
transformation and really we took FPU
together and that's such great
pre-marriage counseling we were on the
same page from day one and so now that
we're getting ready to do this wedding
and help pay for our own wedding
debt-free with cash has been truly
amazing yeah it's been great I sitting
at home we've got a thermometer on the
refrigerator she has a thermometer in
she every month she'd get that out and
she would just take that marker and she
would put a little line on it and it
made it all the way to the top and she's
been carrying it around as a souvenir
ever since then well she should very
well done well I'm glad you guys came to
visit
and it's an honor to meet you Justine
it's not a great great great job you've
done alright let's hear a Kansas style
debt-free scream $35,000 paid off in two
and a half years making 33 then 41 and
now engage Justine from Kansas count it
down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one I love it I love it that is awesome
what a great way to start man ah that's
amazing
very very well done all right open
phones this hour as we talk about your
life and your money triple eight eight
two five five two two five you know
she's making thirty three thousand
dollars a year she starts this deal and
she works her way through it I mean
think about the number of people that
call you're making 133 and can't seem to
find there but with both hands I mean
really impressive very impressive
don't tell me it's an income thing it's
not an income name Ramsey only works for
that brain Kemp people I don't work with
upper income people I work with people I
help people I show people that they can
win and you know what more people win
that make 33 and 44 and 50 for that then
you know I mean I'm not mad at you if
you make 133 but get your frickin act
together seriously you're making 33
that's beans and rice baby I mean that's
you are watching every penny making it
behave absolutely incredible stuff very
well done